what role does the united states
or what role do i
as a human being
who has food today
who has shelter who has a comfortable
life what role do i have when i think
about
north korea when i think about syria
what i think about
maybe the weaker population in in china
well i mean the role is the same role i
have which is to teach and to learn and
to
get the message out that this is
happening because the more people who
understand it the more likely it is that
the united states government will try to
do something about it
um
you know in within the context of who we
are and where we live right and so
you know i write books you do shows you
know
or
maybe you write books too i don't know
but i do not write books but uh i i
tweet
you tweet okay
eloquently but that's not the i guess
that's not the point yes so certainly
this is true and
in terms of a voice in terms of words in
terms of books you are an i would say a
rare example of somebody that has
powerful
reach with words but i was also
referring to actions
in the united states government
what are the options here so war has
costs
and war seems to be as you have
described
sort of potentially increase the
atrocity not decrease it
if there's anything that challenges my
hope for the future is the fact that
sometimes we're
not powerless to help
but very close to powerless to help
because um trying to help
can often lead to
in the near term
more negative effects than positive
effects that's exactly right i mean the
uh you know the unintended consequences
of what we do
can frequently
be as bad if not worse than you know
trying to relieve
the difficulties that people are having
so i think you know you're caught a
little bit
but it's also true i think that we can
be more forceful
i think we can be more forceful without
necessarily war
you know there is this um idea of the
so-called responsibility to protect
and this was an idea that came up uh you
know after kosovo
uh which was what
1999 and when um
you know the the serbs looked like they
were going to engage in a genocidal
program in kosovo and you know it was
basically a program of ethnic cleansing
but it could have gone bad and gotten
worse
not just driving people out but
beginning to kill them
and
the united states and britain
and others intervened you know and
russians were there too as you probably
recall
and
uh
i think correctly people have analyzed
this as a case
in which
genocide was prevented or stopped in
other words the serbs were stopped in
their tracks i mean some bad things did
happen we bombed belgrade and the
chinese embassy and
things like that but
uh you know it was
it was stopped and following upon that
then there was a kind of international
consensus
that we needed to do something i mean
because of rwanda bosnia
and then the positive example of kosovo
right that that
genocide did not happen in kosovo and i
think that argument
is you know has been substantiated
anyway
um and this notion of the uh or this
you know doctrine or whatever of the of
the responsibility to protect them was
adopted by the u.n
in 2005
unanimously
and what it says is
there's a hierarchy of measures
that should be well let me let me take a
step back
it starts with the principle
that sovereignty of a country is not you
don't earn it just by being there
and being your own country you have to
earn it by protecting your people
so every this was all agreed with all
the nations of the u.n agreed you know
chinese and then russians too
that you know sovereignty is there
because you protect your people
against various depredations right
including genocide
crimes against humanity you know forced
imprisonment torture and that sort of
thing
if you violate
that
uh justification for your sovereignty
that you're protecting your people that
you're not protecting them the
international community has the
obligation
to do something about it all right
now then they have a kind of hierarchy
of things you can do you know starting
with
i mean i'm not quoting exactly but you
know starting with kind of push and pull
you know trying to convince people don't
do that
you know to myanmar don't don't do that
to the rohingya people right
then it goes down the list you know and
you get to elite sanctions or
threatening sanctions and then sanctions
you know like we have against
russia
but you go down the list right you go
down the list and eventually
you get to military intervention at the
bottom which they say is the last thing
you know and you you really don't want
to do that
and not only do you not want to do it
but it hit just as you said just as you
pointed out it can have unintended
consequences
right and we'll do everything we can
short
uh you know of military intervention but
you know if necessary that can be
undertaken as well
and so the responsibility to predict i
think is is a is a
you know it was not implementable oh one
of the things it says
in this last category right the military
intervention is that the intervention
cannot
create more damage
than it
relieves right and so for for syria
we came to the conclusion
you know that i mean the international
community in some ways said this in so
many words even though the russians were
there obviously we ended up being there
and that sort of thing but the
international community basically said
you know there's no way you can
intervene in syria
you know it's just no
no way without causing more damage you
know than you would relieve
so
you know in some senses that's what the
international community is saying about
you know
shinjan and the uyghurs too
you know i mean
you can't even imagine
what hell would break loose if there was
some kind of military trouble you know
to threaten the chinese with but
um you can go down that list with the
you know the military leadership of
myanmar and you can go down that list
with the chinese communist party
and you can go down the list you know
with um
others who are threatening you know with
ethiopia
and what it's doing in tigre
and you know you can go down that list
and start pushing i think what happened
there was more of a willingness in the
90s and in the you know right at the
turn of the century
you know to do these kinds of things and
then you know when trump got elected and
you know he basically said you know
america first and out of the world we're
not going to do any of this kind of
stuff
and now biden has has the problem of
trying to rebuild consensus on on how
you
how you deal with these kinds of things
i i think it's not impossible i mean
here i tend to be maybe more of an
optimist than you
you know i think it's not impossible
that the international community can you
know muster some some some internal
fortitude
and and push
harder short of war
you know to
get the chinese and to get the uh again
myanmar and to get others to kind of
back off
of violations of people's rights the way
they are routinely doing it
you